la transformación se lleva al punto
menos 23 menos 23 a este punto aquí
4 - 1 en 4 - 1
4 - 1 a este punto aquí
también lleva al punto menos 55 menos 55
este punto aquí
lo lleva a el punto 7 menos 37 menos 3 a
este punto acá y bueno nos preguntan qué
tipo de transformación podría hacerse
también nos preguntan acerca de pero
vamos a empezar con una traslación una
reflexión o una rotación pues bueno
comencemos si considero este segmento
que une a los dos puntos este segmento
también este entonces parecería que si
primero me desplazo hacia abajo y luego
me desplazo hacia la derecha entonces
puede llevar este segmento en este
segmento pero hay que tener cuidado
porque entonces el punto rojo el punto
rojo que debería terminar en este punto
morado y el punto naranja que debería
terminar en el punto lila no terminan
donde tendrían que estar el punto rojo
terminó en el punto lila y el punto
naranja en el punto morado que no es lo
que quiero por lo tanto no parece que
esta traslación funcione y de hecho a mí
no se me ocurre cómo podría ser un otras
aunque tuviera este efecto
así que digamos que no puede ser una
traslación podría ser una reflexión pues
veamos este segmento y este también
tienen una pendiente de menos dos
tercios así que si yo pusiera aquí justo
en medio de los dos un segmento que
fuera ortogonal a ambos un segmento con
pendiente 23 medios positivos digamos
un segmento con pendiente tres medios
positiva
y se vería algo así más o menos entonces
si está en medio
si más o menos está en medio entonces si
pusieron segmento aquí no me gustó mucho
de que me lo vuelvo a trazar
un segmento bueno lo estoy haciendo
cualitativamente así que no importa
pongo un segmento que esté justo a la
mitad entonces y reflejo este punto rojo
y terminaría en el punto lila perdón
morado y el punto naranja así terminaría
en el punto lila al reflejar alrededor
de esta línea por lo tanto parece que si
podría ser una reflexión
traiga una votación pues una rotación en
mente al menos tiene incluso más sentido
si pongo un punto por aquí uy eso bueno
sí sí se ve si pongo un punto por aquí
en medio y roto entonces parece que el
punto rojo si va al punto morado y el
punto naranja si va al punto
así ropa de este mundo así que también
parece que si puede ser una rotación
bueno que de la transformación de
qué hay de la transformación de
pues veamos la transformación de lleva
al punto 4 - 14 menos 1 a este punto
aquí en el punto 7 menos 37 coma menos 3
aquí
y al punto menos 55
- 55
- 23 menos 23 y bueno en este caso si es
bastante claro que si podría ser una
traslación si primero me muevo hacia la
derecha y luego bajo 2 unidades primero
me muevo tres unidades en la dirección
positiva y luego dos hacia abajo
entonces este punto si va en este punto
y este punto si se transforma
en este punto por lo tanto si podría ser
una traslación ok podría ser una
reflexión pues veamos si quiero que este
punto se vaya en este punto entonces
entonces podría reflejar alrededor de
esta línea pero si reflejo alrededor de
esta línea entonces este punto no se va
en este punto este punto terminaría por
acá así que esta reflexión no me ayuda y
del mismo modo si quiero llevar este
punto en este punto entonces podría
reflejar por una línea por aquí pero en
ese caso esta reflexión acaso que esta
línea no me ayuda a llevar a este punto
en este punto así que no parece ser una
reflexión y que haya una rotación pues
quizás podría rotar para llevar este
punto en este alrededor de este punto y
rotar así pero en ese caso si hago eso
este punto en vez de irse en este punto
va a terminar rotando en algún lugar por
acá
así que esto no me ayuda del mismo modo
acá así que no parece poder ser una
rotación parece que la transformación de
solo puede ser una traslación